how's it going bro so that is Oh Genie
powers match make a [ __ ] but drop the
bass alright so we have solid ice here
it's a Scorpio it's me yeah I'm a
bottom-feeder about a [ __ ] so in this
game you're supposed to pair two lonely
people together and do all their [ __ ]
for them because obviously they're men
together so we have to make sure to
really just cram them in there we're
stuck with Chelsea wicker bunker Oh God
minty Buttershaw you know what sometimes
you just gotta take risks in life am i
right first am i right I'm not seeing
you am i right this is my favorite game
of all time I love this game so how did
you feel in that car that's ridiculous
okay here we are yes
hi are you minty yes I am you must be
Chelsea so fab to me
is she wearing like cassette tape around
her neck she wants something hot with
red meat while she's dating the wrong
person hot with red meat
[ __ ] oh my work ha ha yes they're doing
great now pull the love handle topic
let's talk about facial decor that's
what girls talk about right am i right
ladies
do you like my natural makeup then you
don't ask that via what she doesn't like
it then why are you dating her
let's live spin the wheel
give me a lie give me a good lie big
applause yeah give me give it to me
+20 [ __ ] you look like a natural you
look so natural you got away with it
you look super natural Thanks different
chancing now is food go come on
just you got any good stories yes this
one is good that one time I have found a
pink car and a bicycle that was it that
was a good one that's a fantastic story
it's the winningest one ever how would
you bake my what not much
[ __ ] you do you like my oven don't
compliment her up but she said your
outfit was bad luck help they're quite a
hottie actually will you go out with me
yes yes you pushed all the right buttons
this is like so totally exciting
I don't I want to take our eyebrows and
eat them like crackers they look kind of
tasty do you ever do you ever look at
people and think the same way night we
did it now we're finally gone with
Chelsea hi fun ok what else do we got
let's go and check the shop I don't I
don't care I don't care you can change
your parents and even by oh my god shut
up shut up shut up Hudson he's a
security guard he likes space travel
indie software development oh you're
just full of excitement oh yeah I think
she would fit with a great digger
princess little Kim's is the grave
digger Frank master heart into cute
anime characters and Elder Gods
oh it's date on time hello oh oh oh okay
so I can't a new hair kind of yes Oh
press the refresh button for more
choices we can hide up the fact that
he's a ginger but here's the thing bros
always be yourself
unless unless no one likes you then you
should try and be someone else
greetings fellow human gingers changes
gingers gingers gingers changes ginger
hello bubble what I would like to ingest
our hot red meat dish well you've come
to the wrong man pop red meat um pork
lamb no way it's a hot I would eat it
but I will not enjoy it that's what she
said
it's my hairstyle oh oh oh this is the
moment this is the moment oh we're in
Houston where a lockdown captain
apparently you have an interest in okay
cute anime characters correct I do have
an interest in cute anime encounters
that sounds both rational and logical
you're headed here first folks I can
think of no better way to pass time
Oh God play call okay T cheese vanilla
ice SS present T cheese vanilla ice
double expressive team cheese vanilla
ice is present the one after the first
one the cheese the cheese [ __ ] on the
chief Oh your fashion senses is off the
pie chart man I need to write this
material down this is [ __ ] gold I'm
extremely pleased by your CAD words I
find them what are they plural I don't
okay
will you go out with me you have won my
cardio vascular organ is that his heart
yeah
okay wait way to ruin it
come on not even nipples what is this
so just put it yeah let's go with her
Kaylie she likes indie games superheroes
and ornamental weapons
okay well Kaylie seems actually kind of
cool except she's a train driver that's
his [ __ ] dumb we're gonna [ __ ] her up
give her ginger hair
I can sense hormones being overproduced
in my system she she was a computer game
design yeah okay all right
I like indie games yeah go ahead suck a
dick dinner sir let's talk about oh she
better like my new hair it is clearly
the best wrist hairstyle I see mean is
riskier there's no one else in this
restaurant I love my hair I like oh my
god no oh [ __ ] oh god oh god oh that's
disgusting
agilent's really goes down well on a
date they've got to try and hold it
shrine hold it in no no no no doing
sequence of cards correctly despair
their blushes and their noses yeah
higher or lower lower continuing to
crunch disgusting lower Oh
8% okay well I would take 10% and then
just little less which will read this
all right
I think it works out well okay we did it
hundred percent
let's be in love there you go dog's body
a fire-eater okay oh god he's got to
take a [ __ ]
lower it's the weight how you can
recover from a fart that bad Oh someone
else what someone else come on come on
come on come on come on no no no no no
no no [ __ ] Lily I don't know it it was
the food
[ __ ] okay let's go out yes oh he got
dumped all right all right all right all
right all right all right
press back then that pits over there if
you enjoyed leave a like and that's all
you gotta know is sweet lovely why did
she say those awful things